your
phones why
not I've never been offered this service
at
podcast phone sharping
service 77% you leave at
92% so numerical
guarantee okay I think it's working
beautiful
hello very loud okay that should be good
Brian redb told me to turn up the gain
so the gain has turned up it's a little
bit louder than yesterday's podcast
gotcha
you no all right is this perfect yes
beautiful just like a comedy mic awesome
yeah I had a podcast with Rick Diaz of
all people and like uh Jessica misra and
uh Martin Phillips and Brian redband
he's always giving me advice yeah
shitty my
podcast uh yeah it's good advice he's
like tell them to get closer to the
microphone because I guess some people
don't like to even if they're doing
they're like oh I'm not really invested
in this podcast so I'm going to be far
away I'm not saying that's what you were
doing what happened to the jar of weed
the giant jar of weed I took it no I'm
just kidding I don't know where it is
right now oh
[__] there's a there's a pre-roll under
the table I think yeah let's just smoke
that yeah beautiful Al I'm fiddling with
something so
uh I don't want you to reveal anything
that you're not supposed to but are you
excited for
the yeah I'm excited one year or the New
Year mhm I'm very excited I uh I was
sitting on my grandmother's uh or I was
sitting in my grandmother's room alone
by myself when it was announced for the
HB arena center and now I'm going to be
playing playing in it so it's weird oh
so you were at home watching the Kil
Tony anniversary anniversary so you're a
huge fan of the show before you even got
on it yeah I was definitely I started
stand up and then like 6 months into
going to open mics I started watching
and basically just like writing on the
possibility of being on the show wow so
you're like specifically designed as a
mutant teenage probably to just kill on
the show yeah that was it it's like when
uh in MMA they had people that were
usually in the beginning they were like
in uh wrestling or whatever yeah and
then when they started getting people
that just trained for MMA their whole
life yeah there was like a switch so
that's kind of like you you're the New
Breed I'm that's the first time anyone's
compared me to an MMA
person they should have a league for you
in MMA yeah and they
kids Bob yeah I want to like fight a
bunch of kids in a cage match that'd be
fun children fighting M I don't think I
could get away with it if anyone can get
away with it it's me you yeah you could
be like one of those ml or like the high
school pitchers that say they're in high
school yeah and then they just throw the
baseball really fast at children yeah
like I I should like lie about that and
get on like a t-ball team be like t-ball
All
Stars yeah I think that's that's really
cool that you can do that have you ever
never tried it but you you ever done
anything you weren't supposed to uh it's
not really as like the farthest I've
gone I think is like is stealing a kids
menu but they encourage we all do that
yeah they they want you to do that yeah
you're way over qualified to be doing
that I do that sometimes yeah I I do
eventually want to [__] a child that's
on my bucket list okay I mean you look
like that so you can say
that there's I mean I can't say that say
it not that I would say it say it I'll
say it do it you won't no balls no balls
I want to [__] a
child got him got him it looks like I
[__] trapped you in
here yeah I wish that we had a booster
seat is that rude no no you should have
been more prepared you should have
bought a booster seat I'm a little
pissed off you
didn't here's this thank you this is a
brand new red rose
thermos got this in here I think you're
supposed to put this on the outside or
it's very
pretty just like I go to Red Rose just
for the thermoses
I like your tits but how are you at
keeping my drink warm
yeah this nice weed yeah I mean um I got
it it says Austin Texas oh I got it from
the high Tonight Show have you heard of
that show I think so Creek Victor
Martinez runs it it's an amazing show
it's packed out I was supposed to do it
Wednesday showed up late missed my spot
still got the pre-roll but you still got
the pre-roll yeah do you have a lighter
I do I don't have a lighter on me now I
don't want to go downstairs but this is
canoeing heavy uh
oh what's the cure for canoeing so you
can smoke it vertically like that it's
supposed to make it where it burns more
evenly and then if you switch it around
supposed to also yeah does this help
yeah that that's supposed to do it I
think so if you just shove it down your
throat it will stop
canoeing if you shove my dick in your
ass it has
a did you know that uh I think a lot of
it is cuz how it's packed like if it's
unevenly packed yeah definitely because
I used to pack on like [__] and they
would always constantly
cane I've started doing this cuz I have
this thing this is how I smoke weed now
and it's killing it is killing my throat
yeah this thin little paper it burns up
so quick I changed my voice do you think
it's better to smoke like a blunts or
out of bowls cuz you're smoking so much
butane if you're just constantly
lighting a bowl I think bowls are better
in the short term mhm because it's not
as hot you're only lighting it up when
you need it it saves weed too yeah it's
good for
that I think um joints look cooler and
it's easier in cool situations to do a
joint mhm but uh bowls are just dirty I
don't like how they get dirty and people
don't take care of them Stoners aren't
really the cleanest people all the time
yeah my Bowl's nasty right now and I
just cleaned it like two weeks ago it
gets really nasty I know you have to
wash it
consistently but if you're not smoking
out of a bowl all that [__] that's in
your bowl is in your body yeah and lungs
no I C up every morning it's disgusting
you cough yeah I I cough up like just
yeah it's real gross yeah it's horrible
but it's like our lives are one of such
unnatural stresses yeah that we just
have to consume drug products to feel
good about ourselves and function that's
right there's nothing wrong with
that there's nothing wrong with it
besides the resin in my lungs besides
the dire physical
consequences um I'm just going to check
the chat just to make sure the volume
and everything is
right got it God
W the stupid uh popup as hey did you
know we're doing this new thing on
YouTube I think it's
good so uh kill Tony happens yeah uh
tomorrow tomorrow yes no I'm talking
about like uh for you when you got up
for the first time oh okay yeah that
didn't happen tomorrow no that's
pasted
pass um so you were first week in Texas
and you got up no I was living here for
like uh I think a couple months by the
time that I got picked for Kil Tony yeah
I took a trip here in July and I got on
the mothership open mic and I got to
talk to Adam after that and that's why I
moved here after because of so he
encouraged you to move here mhm he
started giving me uh Cru Chef
spots that's awesome so you move here
you sign up for a couple months or do
you take some time off oh yeah I signed
up every every Monday and you're waiting
in
Shakespeare's were you ever waiting in
the alley never in the alley no I only
heard the baby yeah leg you didn't get
to see the Beer Market that sprung up
organically there was like a whole
underground drug Market going on in that
alley yeah right by the cop too yeah and
they like they should have just like
made it a whole [__] like Renaissance
Fair every Monday in that alley this is
a Renaissance Fair for
virginity and School shooters
yeah it's just such a crazy environment
cuz it already feels like it's Lawless
cuz we're bun of comedians it's not like
you know sanctioned by any governing
bodies yeah so we're already kind of
crazy all of us together some of us
aren't going up most of us aren't going
up so it's like a lot of people you know
they're like why who gives a [__] and
they're doing crazy [__] and then you're
in an alley which is like this is just
outside you know like how Cam and Dave
say yeah it's outside there's no rules
you they just you know people are
getting into fights
D I bummed that I missed
it I know you can just go stand in the
alley yeah it would probably some some
some of the magic will happen if you
just stand there yeah eventually yeah
you'll get some homeless person giving
you an experience that's
similar I
um I kind of like having conversations
with homeless people every now and then
you know every now and then they teach
you something yeah once you get past the
desperation you just need a little bit
of desperation you don't want it to be
overwhelming yeah yeah I want them to be
desperate for my friendship not my
money I now talk toess person if they
want a
conversation you want to get them you're
like a woman you're like I don't want to
have sex with you I just want to you
know get a boost and if you give me what
what I want then I I'll I'll probably
give you some sex or money whatever that
one person wants what's the difference
when I make money I feel like I'm
coming that's
right I don't ever think about money
that much I only think about it when I
feel like I'm about to run out of
it yeah that that's when it's on I don't
think about money I panic about money
yeah exactly more of an
animal brain stem activity in the
frontal cortex it's a survival thing
yeah are you uh poor right now I'm
pretty poor really yeah like I'm I'm
okay but at the same time my my finances
the way they are are not sust
sustainable right now so like I
definitely need to look into something
so you're on savings right now yeah kind
of I'm on savings um I got a little
money from a couple big shows that I
just did but you know I eventually maybe
cross my fingers want to get a door guy
job somewhere you know that would you
know take care of the bills maybe it
could be uh in charge of the doggy door
yeah
between dude they'll install a doggy GE
just so I have a position
there you're getting all the children in
yeah Dam I can bring you in to hear the
non words this is what adults do for fun
I know it would be funny if I was like
security
yeah I mean they have women there so I'm
sure that you can get a job there and
just carry around a taser and you're
just as deadly as anyone exactly I will
take anyone that would
at because you still have the mentality
of a toxic man that's right yeah
I want to see someone
suffer that's all I
want so do you think women are right and
men are wrong or do you think women are
wrong and men are
right damn hitting me with the tough
questions what do you think Hans I think
mostly women are right I think mostly
men are wrong yeah and I wish it wasn't
the case but I hate everything that men
like yeah I
um I'm a man so I like I like a lot of
what it be nice if we were right yeah it
would be very cool but I we're we're
pretty dumb you know I we have way too
much fun to be right we're just more
confident usually like as a species
we're more confident so you don't have
to be all right if you're
confident yeah if you're confident
enough you can
you know take something that was wrong
and just say it's right and then people
will have to say it with you be like
damn that guy's making
sense his muscles really convinced me I
like how broad his shoulders were I do
think women are annoying though I think
women are just as [__] up they're just
not as good at it yeah they're like
they're right but they're pushy about it
it's like God pleas of voice stop yeah
women are always like stop murdering and
raping
taking things that don't
belong why do you have to be so rude
when you ask
me I appreciate that you pointed out a
war crime I just feel like you're making
this awkward for
everyone yeah you really didn't CH uh
check with the Vibes before you
criticized my genocide
yeah whoa there Becky I think um in
conclusion women are
wrong
yeah women are wrong a
lot women are often wrong about how in
danger they
are I think they like to
panic yeah but it's easy for me to say
because I wouldn't know I wouldn't know
um I
think women smell nice I think they're
more afraid of like social interactions
going wrong and not enough of Stranger
in a dark alley or
like I guess bosses and uncles are a
woman's deadliest threats you know what
I know about women
they got
coties yeah coties are bad I and that's
why that's why women are
wrong what do you think the origination
of Cooties is um probably started
sometimes when all the wishes were
coming up and like they the wishes they
probably created cooties if I had Gess
it sounds like a witch thing witch thing
yeah I think think it
was
syphilis yeah probably a combination
with the
two witches and
syphilis witches and syphilis those are
the two things I hate most our wishes
and
syphilis that's what you have to look
out for
yeah wi or if you got syphilis don't
even bother talking to me you know
that's how I feel
yeah I feel like people don't get
syphilis anymore well that's a good
thing cuz I want to talk to them if they
had you wouldn't talk with the hottest
girl in the world if she had syphilis no
she could be she could have syphilis or
be a witch and I'd be like miss me with
that no syphilis witches for me yeah
that's
right it's uh well if there's anything I
learned in life it's that
syphilis witches mhm stay away from
them
um I think that uh the witches in the
polar bear movie with the
knife what is that talking about narn or
Golden Compass okay Golden Compass yeah
I never saw that one cuz um my books are
really good yeah my uh my family thought
there was like satanic stuff going witch
yeah yeah it was that so you are 21 and
you still have parents that are afraid
of the satanic panic at the time yeah
they don't my mom doesn't give a [__]
anymore but when that [__] was coming
out they were like no you got to stay
away from that cuz they were in uh they
were religious at the
time so they were religious in like 2007
yeah exactly mhm that's hilarious yeah
and then they got divorced and then
that's they're like what is the mean
meaning of life yeah what kind of God
would allow
this that's cool so you grew up in a
religious household so you're pretty
like
strict I was like when I like not I
mean by the time I was really growing up
and had curiosity and all that stuff was
gone cuz like um I was religious when my
parents were together and then they got
divorced when I was like five and then
like so after when I turned five I just
turned into a wild [__] you know I
drinking all the yogurt yeah I was a bad
boy at at 5 years old life completely
changed you
remember you remember being
five like it was yesterday so what from
zero to five you were religious yeah I
like zero to five I was like Tian I was
like given everything in my piggy bank
Jes a ten of your pennies uhhuh what
about The Golden Compass when did that
come in I think when I was like around
four or five did you say
2007 yeah then yeah I was like 5 years
old The Golden Compass is great yeah man
I was actually when I was 5 years old I
was doing sermons about how if you watch
Golden Compass you're going to hell and
like so you were all in yeah I got like
three people say bet
day that's fun
yeah um you so The Golden Compass is
like using sort of satanic imagery to be
like look Satan isn't that bad yeah
that's exactly what it was why you
trying to convince me that Satan isn't
that bad that sounds like something
Satan would do yeah yeah you nailed it
so do you do you hate that movie too now
no I love it I love
okay Goa I feel like if it pisses them
off enough maybe we need a little Satan
to help the inflation crisis yeah you
think Satan helps inflation I think he
helps
deflation okay I mean whatever Ronald
Reagan believes
in probably wrong so we could so you're
saying that Satan's got this yeah all
right everything we're not doing is
Satan let's vote for
Satan you look like Satan thing is Satan
out of everyone right now who you think
is Satan I think R Satan is very benign
and Goofy and dumb so probably like Elon
Musk yeah that makes sense and I always
thought Elon was a pretty cool guy he
was pretty chill he was cool until he
started
getting uh he started talking a lot and
then it was like oh this guy's just like
a he made it obvious that he was Satan
yeah when he started talking he's like a
homeschooled person but I think it's
good to be good at business I think he's
very good at that and that's important
because that's just how our world works
yeah so I think he's good at that I just
think he's sort of like Martin scr so I
think he's really smart like cuz like he
had like Twitter for a day and like he
[__] basically started ruining it
right yeah yeah I think he's just like a
genius but maybe not a business genius I
think he is but I don't know I'm not I'm
definitely not a genius so I mean yeah I
mean I don't think he's good at Twitter
but I think he's good at being like okay
we're making a rocket okay yeah I like
uh I'm going to spend five minutes
picking or five days five months picking
the right wheels or whatever yeah he's
caring about boring [__] yeah and
Perfection and stuff like that and like
convincing other people mhm to give him
money
and he's got like
that no emotion thing where he can just
like fire
30,000 people at once and be like it's
business
baby yeah like no empathy yeah that
that's what it's
called took me a while I was like
whoa then I remembered what we were
talking it's good weed it's very good
weed yeah I think uh who who do you
think is a devil maybe someone like uh
Taylor Swift Taylor Swift is probably
the devil is someone like Taylor Swift
there's no way that that's her whole
personality she's got to be [__] up in
some way yeah no no she's definitely
[__] up what do you what do you think
what do you think she does that's [__]
up I bet I bet she killed cats when she
I think she's super self-centered in
conversation she's like oh my God guys
well obviously $10 coupon from Macy's
bet she did something like killing
cats she she has to I would kill cats if
I was Taylor Swift I think she would hit
somebody like a homeless person with her
car and drive away yeah like I don't I
can't deal with this right now yeah yeah
that makes sense she's probably hit like
hit and run at least two or three times
how can you not when you're TI or
Swift I think that she probably
participates in consumer culture that
relies on slave
labor and she doesn't care too much yeah
we kind of all do that you
know
yeah if you're if you're an American you
probably rely on slave labor so what do
you do do you just feel bad and just you
know give like a Hail Mary or do you you
know start bombing certain key targets
um yeah I say you bomb all the sweat
shops with all the children in them you
know just get the source I would say you
bomb some corporate office yeah during
the middle of the night just so they
don't have a place where they can do
their thing either one works you you
know you either kill the kids or you
kill the corporate but either way you
you get rid of the yeah I know which
one's easier yeah killing kids is way
easier killing kids is so yeah in a
corporate thing once they they can hire
security well you can only do it you got
to do it all at the same time or else
they're going to know yeah so you got to
coordinate and just it wouldn't be that
hard just do like a a coordinated strike
on all that make sure no one CIA yeah
you think there's any members of you
know the CIA or the FBI in standup
comedy in Austin who do you think is a
plant oh oh
um
probably I would
say Ty Rivera Ty rera yeah he's
definitely a plant for the
CIA it makes sense you know well you
wouldn't expect it yeah that's the face
hats they're all fake yeah he just puts
them on every night to go out it's all
fake he
just but the fact is that he's really
good at comedy so
yeah I mean when you're CIA you got to
learn CG skills like [__] the CIA show I
could tour yeah they can make three
times the money yeah man well it's like
some people they got to learn taond they
got to join CIA and other people they
got to learn stand up com and also after
that gig you can't have any other
undercover gigs you're pretty much done
cuz your name and face is out there now
yeah that's true but like that's why
it's like a like a lifetime job you know
yeah that's how how you know there's no
the reason comedy Ty rer is the reason
why cocaine isn't in the green rooms
anymore he's been snitching on all of us
yeah I think that
uh it's sad that there's so much uh
suffering in terms of sweat shops and
stuff yeah and there's absolutely
nothing that we can do about it we
should buy a ticket to like Malay
or Honduras wherever they are and
somewhere we should give them hugs you
know you know the world is basically
like Hunger Games you got district one
which is America and England and then
you got District Two which is like Korea
they make our TVs and cars but then you
get to District like eight and nine
they're making our you know bananas and
you want to be up there you don't want
to be making
like uh
clothes yeah you it's holy [__] dude did
you just read Hunger Games cuz like
that's blowing my mind right
now just always in the bag of the brain
well I was reading a lot about Latin
American coups and how in the 1970s and
60s and 80s we just spent all this money
on [__] up anyone that we didn't like
yeah and we were like no we got we want
this guy in charge and this guy in
charge it's like what is that all for
it's like for like bananas like sugar
it's like is that really worth it and
now we have all these immigrants and
stuff but I don't know it's just like uh
yeah it's just weird how the world is
like yeah you should be happy making our
bananas you could be you know serving
some lesser Lords yeah you could to be
like Hunger Games in in in the way that
we we like number
one but in the number one there's even a
more number one yeah what's what's the
number one it's cool I mean like the CEO
of H Burton yeah but it's cool to be in
America and being poor if you're poor in
Korea it's like you're poor in a country
that doesn't even yeah I got a real
question who do you think the cat is
ever te of real life is probably and it
can be guy or girl Tashi 69 go 69 I
completely
agree he's always being put in jail yeah
man
bro's he's that's gonna be like part of
his new song
yeah
bro I hav't listen to tekashi
69 probably in
ever he made good music videos yeah I
was like at one of these cool hip-hop
places in like the Bronx and they were
playing music videos and I was like whoa
that's pretty cool and they're like yeah
that's tekashi 69ine I was like oh I
just thought he was a joke yeah I I
don't know people actually listen to his
music but he his music videos were
really trippy I forget how or why or
what they look like they kind of I think
from what I've seen they're like they
kind of like remind of like Nicki Minaj
or Mega they kind of all look the
same yeah they're reallying the same
Vibe yeah exactly which is fine [__]
everything but um [__] you him
especially his music's not that great
from what I've listened to I I haven't
studied enough to CAU g69 to make these
then why does everyone know his name
well I mean he gets a lot of clout for
like being in media and like he was a
part of the those trials and he snitched
and stuff I think oh right
yeah that's what I'm going to do I'm
going to go to I'm going to join a gang
go to prison snitch and then I don't
have to do comedy ever
again yeah you could be the Rick Diaz of
a prison cell Rick Diaz of a prison as
long as I'm getting as long as I'm
getting you
know raped in my butt oh yeah yeah the
old butt rape yeah what what's the point
of going to prison if you're not in the
mood for that
yeah are you uh going to uh go to prison
you think I hope not I don't think I
would survive while in
prison um do you think uh the American
prison system is a
nightmare I don't know
to be quite honest I do not know I would
how do you know anything honestly you
know that's I don't know much things to
be honest have you ever been dealt have
you ever dealt with the American justice
system I I got a ticket one time that I
paid online oh yeah so you got caught
for speeding yeah I uh I got in a wreck
and then it was technically because I
ran a light technically or yeah well I
feel like it was someone else's fault
but there was no way I could prove it
someone uh was getting off the freeway
and he didn't use his blinker and he
didn't yeld immediately when he turned
into my lane and so like I got out of
his way which I should have just wrecked
into him and you got out of his way yeah
and then like I was stunned I wasn't I
was paying attention to that [__] and
then I ran a light like 3 seconds
afterwards so you didn't get in a wck I
did get in a wreck but it wasn't with
that guy it was someone that was
crossing the red light that I was you
know not paying attention to so you your
this car's coming in you swerve to void
and then you run the
light yeah yeah so this car is coming in
I just swerve into another Lane I'm like
whoa and then there's a another car
coming at this intersection yeah boom so
you crashed into him because you were
avoiding the other guy yeah
exactly no
no did you have a dash cam I didn't I
didn't yeah I was
underprepared no dash cam well that
sucks because
uh yeah I mean it it was just a ticket
right yeah it was just a ticket uh my
insurance took care of the poor people
at that inter
SE and then the homeless guy that I
killed didn't have any family so you
know it's all good real Taylor Swift of
you yeah exactly I might be the devil
who
knows definitely could be um the
devil so uh what do you think about uh
the New Year's shows coming
up I'm excited yeah I'm also kind of
nervous have you you've done eight that
kind of crowd before how many people is
it 8,000 I think yeah that's what I've
heard wow yeah yeah I've done 8,000
before it's pretty fun yeah I mean it's
crazy because online we do that and you
know 10 times that yeah it's weird when
you think about it in a Auditorium or an
arena it's just magnified M so it's it's
like a lot of energy MH and uh yeah I
think it's good to let that energy flow
through you yeah so that's fun yeah you
definitely just got to Vibe with it like
I did those theaters and that was kind
of the same thing just on a smaller
scale and I'm really glad I did that
because it kind of gives me an idea of
what it's going to be like but still
like it's hard to imagine 8,000
yeah but everyone isn't reinforcing
their desire to be there so it's just
like a compounding effect it's almost
like they are willing it to happen yeah
so you just have to like go into what
you know how to control those
situations yeah cuz they're going to be
trying to do it too because they all
paid
money and the good thing about kill Tony
is that the structured part is over in a
minute and after that it's just you're
in an arena full of people just hanging
out yeah that's wild yeah it'll be
nights yeah do you have to do it two
times in a row yeah does it ever like uh
like I can't like so how is it like when
you have to do two minutes like that
close in a row because I know there was
that time like a couple weeks like a
week ago where you were doing like six
shows in like three weeks or two weeks
yeah what was that like it was just a
lot you know a lot of jokes that I had
to do but I just have like a crop of
jokes that I have and I just go through
them it really didn't change too much I
wrote more in preparation but it was
just like a thing Upstream like when I
was happening it was just like yeah I
mean I've done multiple show we all do
multiple shows all the time yeah so that
wasn't hard it was just uh yeah I mean
it is what it is but but um yeah I I
just worked harder further up so that I
would have a good crop of jokes and I
was like I don't have to be a stress if
I didn't have a bunch of stuff that I
could potentially do then I would have
been stressing more and I would have
panicked last minute but I felt like I
had a good amount of stuff and maybe I
should do more Panic writing yeah that
produces a different type of thing yeah
I like I feel like I kind of do that for
roast and stuff like that I do like
Panic like that's a lot of panic writing
for me
yeah I have a roast coming up quite
nervous about roasts are such a pain in
the ass show I'll do a show any day
tomorrow yeah sure a roast you book me
for tomorrow I'm like [__] yeah maybe I
could do things that I did for another
fat guy mhm roast are weird because like
in a way that you can't prepare for them
and then when it's over it's over you
know yeah it's like the have to write
stand and it's like maybe I should be
writing like this for every show that I
do that pays me 50 bucks because that's
how much I wrote for these 50 bucks
yeah that's
true it's uh it is crazy to think like
sometimes I go out on the weekends and I
prepare less for that than I do roasts M
cuz the weekends I know what I'm going
to do and I just have to go through the
recipe yeah like a roast it'll pay me
like nothing and then take up like 10
minutes of my time and um a stage time
and then I have to write for like so
much cuz it's like your personal they're
getting us to write based on our
personal professional shame yeah so yeah
it gets nasty I don't like rust too much
yeah um but I feel like it's good to
work that hard mhm
so what are you thinking right
now do you want to uh make a viral clip
let's make a viral clip right now okay
let's just pretend like you
said that
um you know the that Tik Tok
is the best app yeah and I'll be like
uh and you can own me you know Tik Tock
kid
owns uh
old what what do what do you think I
look like uh Asian yeah Asian's
definitely in there um obviously and
then nerd old
Asian yeah you got to keep it simple
Asian nerd so I'm like I have a job at
Google yeah and I'm like actually Tik
Tok is the most most harmful thing you
little kids have such short attention
spans no you're Asian so it's got to be
like
an is very
better shut up and then you could Vape
yeah tick tocking teen Vapes an Asian
nerd's
face shut up dumb Asian old
nerd yeah it hurts because he is a
child and he has objective it hurts
because you're you're dumb and
olddy he can destroy
me a child when I'm so much older than
him anything just born can destroy me
yeah you're dis I no Advantage I've been
spending 2030 years more on Earth than
you and I've gained almost no it's
actually been a detriment to me I don't
I don't think this is GNA go
viral you're I right yeah it's I mean
but we can keep it up if you
want well you
know I I don't really I'm not like a
huge riffer yeah I'm not either I'm
terrible at riffing really yeah who's
the best riffer you think I graffy uh
yeah I rafy is really good at it and
then like Casey like he does likey 45
minutes where he just [__] Rifts yeah
locally if we're talking about locally I
I think I mean theatrically yes I'm
talking about just like when you're in a
conversation with someone and it's just
like oh for like podcast and yeah I Ry
like uh Michael Ridley I feel like he's
really bitty yeah he's good at
it are you more
like uh storytelling
conversationalist um usually I try just
get to the kisses as soon as possible
when it comes to conversations yeah I'm
just like are you motivated by horniness
I don't get that sense from you yeah you
seem like a pretty good guy to talk to
you're not always distracted and [__]
yeah well I I appreciate that you get
that Vibe but I'm usually like pretty
distracted in my head I can tell that
sometimes you're not giving 100% yeah
maybe that's cuz you're saving it up for
some sex yeah I'm saving it up for the
sex that's what I do okay that's
interesting yeah so why do you think
you're so motivated by
sex I don't know honestly I I would say
that sex is something that we're all
motivated by yeah I'm motivated by
feeling good yeah ex I just want to like
rub my dick on things sometimes yeah I
feel like that's what we're all supposed
to do is just to see what we can rub our
penises or our genitalia on well I feel
like uh having like a steady like a
scratching post to rub your dick on is
good because then it's more sustainable
and reliable and there's not a lot of
like extra fluff fluff but there can be
a lot of extra I feel like if you rub
your penis on a like a cheese grater you
won't ever rub your penis on anything
ever again
yeah which that would be so
uh do you wna do you want to try that
out with me after the podcast we can rub
on each other no on the greaters you
know we can buy a couple
graders yes cool it's all about the
pressure although I don't think it takes
much pressure to for that to hurt so do
you think like sex is like you know
you're just like motivated by like
endorphins so you just want to like feel
the most and you just want to experience
that or do you think it's hormones your
just body is like in this
unreasonable illogical mode where you're
sexing all the time I think butts are
nice but that's all I
know yes I would say that uh it is what
you're interested in I think that's
great that
that um you know you enjoy butts because
it's so sad to go out in life when you
can't enjoy butts yeah
like I'd say the best thing about butts
are when someone is like look at my butt
like when they want hey look at my butt
yeah and then I've never really had that
happen to me a lot you haven't had
someone that's been like I am so used to
butts that don't want to be seen that if
I see a butt that wants to be seen it's
sort of like oh that's why it's so like
yes you know yeah don't you think it's
like yes Whenever there one that wants
to be seen yeah it's like I can stare at
this to my heart's content mhm and
there's nothing anyone will do about it
yeah that's right it's it's for your
eyes it's meant for your eyes yeah so
you like it when girls are doing
that it it I it's appreciated yeah I
like the hunt you like the hunt I like
just spotting it in the wild yeah yeah
that's that's the fun part about it just
seeing which ones are out for your
eyes
eyes eyes so do you ever feel like that
are you ever like you see someone you
know checking out your booty and you're
like look at my butt I try to make mine
visible for other really well please
don't it's hard though cuz I don't have
a booty but I I work with what I got you
know yeah I'm working with the giant
pair of loafers back there so I have no
idea what it's like for you I know it's
you're lucky if you're big voloptuous
rumper well thank you Heath I really
wasn't expecting that today well you
deserve it buddy buddy old pal I wish I
had a big ass yeah do you not I I have
honestly I've never really checked out
your it's not a thing men don't really
check out but girls are checking out
each other's butts they like let's see
what you got okay yeah got a F-150 of
asses yeah I get intimidated by uh by by
broad shoulders if someone's got broad
shoulders I'm like whoa I can't talk to
that guy that's a mechanical advantage
yeah yeah because the wider your
shoulders the bigger your reaches I just
know that guy's better than me he has
more volume yeah you could fit inside of
him that's not good yeah he if he has
all that much more
[__] then it's like he's going to be
better than you he's
like
exactly I think that guys can be sexy
yeah yes what do you find sexy in a man
a
woman shape
nice um I think it the more guys look
like women the sexier they are yeah like
when guys have nice broad
hips and child birthing Wast yeah
exactly child holding and when they have
nice big voluptuous titties
too I didn't realize the waist was up
here I thought the waist and hip were
like the same thing
yeah I kind of I kind of thought they
were too to be honest I guess that's
what this what would you call this part
if not the waist the thorax I thought
like the these things like the pelvis or
the hip bones the thorax to pelvis ratio
yeah imagine describing a woman like a
bug oh yes I love your spilop
pods you got nice but I don't know what
they have antenna yeah I don't know what
but
yeah but there's got to be a guy that's
just like man that woman's
abdomen or I mean I'm sure bug guys they
probably compare women to bugs which you
know yeah he look like he could be a bug
guy you know I I I used to dig for
earthworms when I was a lad so three
years ago three years ago I was digging
for the earthworm SP who doesn't love
doing that it's hard hard to find good
soil anymore yeah I feel like earthworms
don't even exist anymore yeah they're
like fireflies mhm you don't even know
about fireflies I know I know about
fireflies back in the day you know about
the Owl City song Fireflies yeah man
that was my jam when I was like a little
little little boy fir FES in the night
sky look like shooting stars is it that
song song it's
like yeah I don't
know it's one of those nonsense songs
where it's the melody is so good that
the lyrics don't make any sense yeah it
didn't matter but it just worked for
that time imagine how many more of those
people we could have if we lived in
Scandinavia yeah CU those people need a
healthy culture to survive they can't
just be spouting nonsense when the Jews
are being genocided yeah so I I didn't
know that Scandinavians were do they do
they have yeah Dr Luke the person who
sexually assaulted Lady Gaga is from
there oh so Scandinavians are just a
problem
Kesha I mean they make a music okay
there's a guy that just makes all the
pop songs that lives in Norway or got
somewhere okay
cool yeah they make Good Music ABBA yeah
uh I I don't know who ABBA is I don't
aba's just great it's like it doesn't
matter what era you're in they make good
songs like melodically okay Dancing
Queen okay yeah I know that one are they
still like bopping around the people
that made Dancing Queen I don't know
okay I'm going to give them a apple
music look them up on Apple music when I
get home it's just it just lacks any
context or any urgency their songs are
very light it's just it's like it's not
like American Music where it comes comes
from pain or sorrow not like Amy win
house yeah it's just really good
songs good nice little Feelgood s yeah
nice that's what we're are good people
what you're saying yeah they're the best
hell
yeah they're the little Amish people on
the tee of European colonized
colonialism that got all the benefits
and none of the downsides hell yeah I'm
going them Scandinavia at least a visit
at some point now yeah you should I'm
going to it will be fun um do you want
to come whenever I go to Scandinavia I
do yes oh yeah we can make one of those
cute little
Vlogs those take forever to make yeah
you make your own videos no I I don't
make content yeah I just was working on
stand
up yeah um I don't I don't know I feel
like people talk about it people want to
make thing about [__] content is it
takes so much work to make if it was
easy it'd be so much better yeah you
have to watch it you have to really want
to make it those people that do that mhm
that is torture is whatever you're
focused on and like I'm just more
focused on writing material you
know yeah you don't have to do that I
think that is kind of a sh thing to be
into yeah I mean it it's just like
putting more eggs in more baskets or
yeah putting your eggs in other baskets
which is fine which is smart but I think
stand-up comedy is more direct there's
less
editing there's less things that don't
actually help you get better at standup
when you're getting when you're
practicing standup you're doing uh I
mean that's the only way to do it you
can't get better at stand up by doing
some weird [__] mhm so yeah definitely
it's exactly so it's honest so you're
not going to get LED astray doing this I
know it's hard but it's better for my
whatever and then you're doing some
[__] if it's hard then it's you're
directly getting better from it and
stand up MH it's not like a job where
you have to you know do mind numbing
things for no reason and those people I
I feel sorry for when they get into
comedy because they need to be told what
to do yeah and nobody's telling them it
takes someone that actually wants to do
what they're doing they don't want to
just like look like they're doing
something they actually want to do the
thing that they're doing mhm and I don't
know like the difference between that
standup and like vlogging or any other
kind of like content that you would post
on the Internet is you like make it
better constantly throughout the year
like you you make progress on it rather
than just posting it all at once yeah
which I think is kind of neat it's a
more more long-term way to appreciate
something mhm that these children know
nothing about it develops
like better because of that I
think yeah it's more
organic exactly and you can trick people
easier because you do the same act over
and over again yeah what time are you
trying to get out of here whenever you
want man I I can say all night oh we can
party all night that's just what I
wanted to hear I'm just kidding we can
we can sub to you so that's a cool thing
you're doing yeah I'm addicted to nasal
spray so it's not even for medical
reasons no like I just like I started
using it one time don't do it again cuz
like my nose is really Snuffy like a
couple years ago and it just clears it
up yeah and now here we are I got to use
you just blast the [__] out of your nose
yeah but every 3 four hours 3 four hours
you like snorting yeah yeah the bottle
says that of fenamin it is oxy metazine
Oxy Cotton it does sound a lot worse
than it is but yeah it sounds like well
how would you know you're not a doctor V
what if you're giving yourself cotton
lung you can buy a Dollar General off
the that makes me worried even more yeah
it's probably even worse than [__]
Dollar General cocaine yeah man it's the
best that's crazy it's like and get you
a b i say can I try but I don't really
want to stick it up my nose that's right
I'll just get you a bottle next yeah we
could be spray Bros oh yeah man y you
want to take a spray from my whatever
what do you call it your guess a bottle
a bottle yeah I to show you my butt
afterwards yeah that's how you get all
the butts so what's your strategy in
getting butts um exactly what you just
said I just I just show off my bottle
and that usually does the trick my
strategy was to do comedy and then wait
around yeah that's basically it trying
to get [__] without comedy is stupid
yeah it's it's tough the kind of guys
that get [__] without doing comedy are
the stupidest dest people alive I barely
get it with comedy so imagine where I
was at before so what has your sex life
like been
it's like it's got a lot of potential
it's got It's promising yeah like I got
um but yeah as of now who
knows yikes I know it's not
fun well I don't think that it should be
an issue I think that you will get to a
place where you're sick of sex soon yeah
well you'll look on these days with a
fondness you know what's not fun about
it people are asking what's your sex
life what's your sex
I'll tell you what my sex is like you
got to be like it's not that great
that's the best answer though you don't
want to be a guy that's like oh dude I'm
getting so much
[__] are you sure that guy that that
guy seems cool
man rad disgusting I mean I guess if
you're like tekashi
69 yeah didn't we just say he was uh
like canace everine she's a badass yeah
that's our catniss everine that's like
on Katniss everine on uh Aderall yeah
it's true I wish there was a movie in
The Hunger Games where everyone was
vaping and they were uh on Tik Tok and
they were all just like that's probably
in the prequel that just came out
they're all on Tik
Tok yeah so do you think transgender
people are an Abomination upon on God
and man or do you think that alternative
genders have existed throughout history
and
species yeah that's good I know they
like I've seen movies where like in the
80s where there's like uh the three
breed yeah you mean shales yeah yeah
yeah so tale they're at least that old
yeah I
mean there's only supposed to be too we
don't have freedom they want freedom for
their guns but not for gender yeah they
got to have freedom for the gun the
genders right it's so weird how like
most people that are obsessed with that
are usually not that confident in their
gender yeah that is what it's about is
like if you it's like they have to be
like no you're a man and you're never
not going to be a man and so they go
like no this is how I handle it you can
be a woman but it's like why are you
that thinking about it you should not be
thinking about your gender you should
just be trying to be a normal person
most of the time I don't know some
people it's like they're self-conscious
about it because it's brought up as a
question and but it's a lot of it is
just that's how a lot of people connect
with each other that's our programming
that's our brainwashing by taking a side
and whatever the Hot Topic is you know
yeah and it's just a lot of it people
like to take sides
yeah what's a side that you like to take
I'm I'm the person that likes to take
side with all the people that like
doesn't like to take side you're like I
don't watch the news kind of guys yeah
I'm I I hang out with the don't take
side guys I think that's smart I think
that's healthier own I think our current
public discourse is toxic and negative
yeah I think it's better to not listen
to it CU it'll make you it'll on average
bring you down a little bit yeah it'll
make you happy but it also make you sad
and I think on average it's a little
lower yeah I honestly I should get
better about paying attention to like
not necessarily politics but also like
politics and news and what's happening
I'm really bad about that what do you
think about like just if we were to do
like the world according to Heath CZ and
you were trying to describe what's
happening right now what would you start
with oh I'm so self-centered I don't I
don't I would be like there's bad stuff
happening in Israel right now um there
bad stuff where like where people are
dying and little babies are not having
fun and over there that'll that's a bad
place for babies terrible place for
babies I know that um I think I think
maybe are not also having fun I they
have they have a part in it somehow I'm
I'm not sure what you're thinking that
they could be having fun they should be
having fun yeah I've heard that the Jews
should always have fun that's one of the
rules of the genev convention yeah
exactly Jews should always have fun from
this day yeah six day Six Flags tickets
for all the Jews dude if you're Jewish
you should get 6 FOX tickets I feel like
yeah it's just weird to see when their
Jewish brainwashing is useless and like
gone too far yeah cuz like most of the
time they're right and most of the time
they're like actually what you said was
offensive against Jews and you know like
Jews have been so persecuted and it's
horrible you're like oh yeah that is
true but now they're like murdering
people and they're still saying that
[__] it's like oh you're just this is
autopilot for you it's just most of the
time it's correct yeah I've heard that
they were murdering people but what are
the what are the reasons I don't know
cuz they want their land oh gotcha I
want to take it
gotcha just you know quit being greedy
man they're God so much Lance who want
Siberia Palestine you're now in Siberia
yeah did we'll give you electricity kind
of it's kind of [__] up if you ask me
it's just a land grab it's a good old
ethnic cleansing exactly so that place
they're going to get rid of all it looks
like they're going to get rid of all the
Palestinians in Israel so Israel is just
going to be 100%
juj that's a that's a weird thought I
mean at least it'll fix
things I I I I have no idea man at least
we can visit Israel
now that's as long as I can visit Israel
that's I mean I can't visit Israel I
just want to I want to tell my dick
jokes in
Israel yeah I mean they love comedy do
they do they like dick jokes over there
yeah uh it depends yeah it's so funny
that they love comedy because religion
is the death of
Comedy yeah in terms of actual real
world Game of Thrones type [__] yeah so
they have you think they balance each
other out maybe for the for the Jewish
people yeah I think because they're so
suppressed with the religion that when
they're free they're like they're doing
it all they're like using their mind for
like Goofy joke jokes yeah I was told
this was bad but when you're training
your mind to read the Torah for whatever
you're learning the words you're
learning sentence
structure and uh that trains you to be a
comedian it's just most of them don't
and then once a few of them get out yeah
then it's just
deadly yeah it's
interesting so you want to wrap it up we
can't we did like 17 hours yeah
I feel like we did more than enough
then someone said this looks like a
Junior High Counseling
meeting it is
um good at it you can always look into
that counseling little children asking
them about their sex life yeah you're 21
he's 21 I'm not he's an adult I'm not
wait you're 20 no I'm actually like 13
14 something like that I had a
conversation with a kid where we talked
about sex yeah thank you
Hans I uh I enjoy talking with you you
seem very honest and normal yeah yeah
what do you want to do now it's up to
you my friend okay my
pal okay well uh yeah I'll see you guys
around bye
bye I think that that's good enough nice